okay chair you're now live
thank you very much tom well good
evening uh fellow councillors
and members of the public joining us on
youtube
uh it's very sad occasion that we're uh
thinking of this evening in a minute
we're going to have a two minute silence
i just would like to read a statement
first very short one
we remain seated with our heads bowed
for the two minutes be appropriate would
say the disruption of
getting up sitting down re adjusting all
your uh
tablets so i would like us to remember
his royal highness student edinburgh
and the contribution he made in
supporting her majesty the queen
the whole nation is saddened by his
death and our thoughts and prayers
are with her majesty and the royal
family
so we now commence our two-minute
silence
all right thank you uh councillors and
officers for that
now we'll proceed with the full council
meeting
at uh on the 12th of april
2021 and we start with
apologies and uh roll call
so uh who's doing that is that sandra
doing that or
yes chair shall i do the roll call first
yes please and then there you go okay
thank you chair
councillor bounton yeah present
councillor brenton
[Music]
uh councillor cottle hunking don't
right no she's not present thank you
councillor craigie
present councillor dart
present canceler gab
[Music]
hawking he's just joining now sandra
okay thank you uh councillor heppell
present counselor hicks
present counselor hodson
present chancellor hurley president
councillor inch president councillor
james
president kensler jones
present counselor langford
present hencely laws present
counselor leather agent
penciller lock president pence lima golf
present councillor mackenzie
present councillor manley
president councillor newton
president counselor pennington
councillor rossi president
cancer watson president and councillor
wiseman
here thank you chair
apologies um we've received
councillor clark councillor ford
councillor hutchins and councillor
cottle hunken
thank you sandra right so i moved to
item
two which is the cancel minutes and
there's two sets there
and we'll do what we did last time i'll
read through the pages
if there's any inaccuracies please
challenge them
and then we'll we'll take both of them
together
but you either say four for the first
order against whatever or abstain
and so you do the two together save a
long time
right so i'll start with page four on
these are the council minutes of
monday the 1st of february page 4
page 5 page 6
page 7 page 8 page 9
age 10 age 11
page 12 page 13
page 14 page 15
page 16 and they'll go to the
monday 22nd of february yeah councillor
hodson raised her hand
claire you're muted
sorry about that um thank you mr
chairman
i've got a couple of queries on page 11.
right with regard to
a comment that my fellow colleague
councillor pennington declared an
interest it's the one two three four
fifth paragraph down it doesn't really
make much sense as you read it
um to ask what this actually meant
and uh i think if we
should suggest an amendment to say have
been brought across
privately owned land right
because you know um i don't know how
councillor pennington feels about that
perhaps he'll respond in a moment
the second point on um
that is the resolution that the imminent
production of tdc's carbon plan be noted
and that the plan be brought to the next
full council meeting in april
which it obviously hasn't
um and we need to have an update on that
um have we got to page 19 yet
or is that in the dash no that's but
those two issues
um i suggest we actually note or
um amend especially the council of
pennington one i don't know how he feels
about that
right is councillor pendleton there
yes i'm here chair you have a problem
with the uh
amendment to that uh minute well no
because uh
the the um corridor is going to be
across my land and it is a
interest i wanted to declare a personal
interest and i i'm happy to keep it as
it is thank you
oh you'll keep it as it is okay all
right
so um i mean i think the important thing
is
you have declared an interest um
in terms of your land and how it would
affect you so
right counselor um comes from
a minute to stay as it is so well i'm
sorry
mr chairman i don't want to argue the
point and i know what councillor
pennington was actually declaring an
interest for but reading it
for the uninformed or those that don't
know that council of pennington's land
was affected
uh it doesn't say across his land
or privately owned land so it could be
any
you know as it would have to have been
brought across
ground right
it doesn't make i i
understand the point you're making a
council penny says you want to
uh respond i'm happy to leave it as this
chair and you must decide
right well we i know i won't decide the
council will decide
whether they want to pass these minutes
uh
with the amendment or not in which case
i'll have to take the amendment first
and then go back to the substantive
minutes
so do you want to put that forward as an
uh amendment um
answer sorry hudson
yes i do i think it needs to be
privately owned
ground councillor pennington's ground
right um because i think for anybody
reading these historically they wouldn't
have any idea
why it was causing councillor pennington
a lot of difficulties
okay so if you've got a second for that
then
so mckenzie
councillor mckenzie secondly now right
so in that case we have to take this
this amendment first in a minute so i've
had my hand up for a time here
sorry sorry counselor uh h i i don't
have this
the scream of the participants on a
minute that's my fault
okay yes yeah i can see it now cancer
hicks yes
uh as one who gets involved as agent
from most of the landowners
all it needs is to put the word his out
to the word across
right is
councillor penny did you happy with that
yes chair
to speed the meeting please right
okay so that amendment then that
correction then perhaps
uh of his to go there
if there's all agreement on that then uh
when we get to the end
of these minutes i will uh ask that
uh that that that change be
noted in those minutes for approval okay
thank you you got councillor haynes his
hands raised right
thank you chair just to take out
councillor hudson's point about
the carbon plan it's been delayed to
june um
for one reason is because certain maps
have to be included and they're not
ready yet and secondly it's felt that it
will be better
presented in june in order to get
maximum publicity
after the purder period has expired
right explanation thank you for that
so we got to page 16 that's those first
set of minutes
so we moved to monday 22nd february and
page 17 18 19
20 yes sorry cancer hicks
yeah uh fourth paragraph confirmation of
the value
finance manager will check and report
back
when right
answer that piece
david are you
uh is somebody muted here i can't i
can't hear anything
he's just trying to get some sound back
on his laptop
no
no can't hear you
um church i just just spoke to david he
said he
reported directly or responded directly
back to council
councillor bushby who raised the raise
the question
uh right see councillor bushby is not in
in a sense that he's had that
right okay all right councillor hicks
well i i would like to have known the
figure as well why is it
you know limited
okay well i don't think there's a
problem with that i think that could be
sent out to cancers don't you um
steve hurst uh chair yes that's right uh
we'll get the the emails circulating to
all counsellors
right good solved that was page 19 page
20 page 21
22 23 24
25 26
27 28
29 30 31
32 33
30 no sorry 33 is uh is the last one
right yeah councillor hodgson's got a
hand raised no
yes no just simply to mention the same
point that councillor hicks raised
apologies up and down now right okay
so i'm going to move those two sets of
minutes so you say uh
for or abstain or against
us we'll need a secondary second chair
thank you good so uh sandra
uh if you would like to begin
yes thank you chair council about him
councillor brenton uh abstaining for the
first i wasn't present
and a four for the second thank you
councillor bright four for both
councillor brown
councillor bushby
council christie four for both
councillor craigie all for both
canceler dart
yep fall for both councillor gab
four for both councillor hackett
all for both chancellor haynes
bopper both sorry chancellor harding
four and four councillor
hawkins yeah four for both
cancer hippo
yeah thank you councillor hicks
four for both kensal hobson
all for both pencil hurley
all for both rich
or for both counselor james
four for both councillor jones
four for both penciller langford
or for both chancellor laws all for both
chancellor leather warfare both
counselor lock
both counselor mcgoff
yes for both councillor mackenzie
four for both councillor manly
poor for both councillor newton
four for both chancellor pennington four
for both
councillor rossi abstain and four
thank you councillor watson or for both
councillor wiseman or for both
thank you chad thank you very much so we
moved to item three now public
contributions and we have
one speaker uh mr alan smith who's uh
got the three minutes to make his
presentation the council
if you would like to go ahead please uh
mr smith yes hello truman
um don't need to say much all i want to
make it make a comment on the way this
has been handled
first of all i don't think it's
democratic that i should speak
now and then the councillors
discuss it councillors then take a vote
without me being able to answer any of
the counsellor's queries
i don't think it's democratic at all
that's all i want to say i don't want to
comment on the
actual thing you're going to discuss i
don't care which way you vote so
carry on that's it right
is that the conclusion of your that's
the conclusion yeah
okay well i have to assure you that
we're working within uh the democratic
rules so
uh yeah you may be but it may be
recognizable anybody
with a bit of common sense which key
that isn't reasonable that i should
say i was going to comment on it now
i'll comment on it
then you discuss it some of you will
come up with things you don't understand
may not
it's only right that i should be able to
come back and answer your queries before
you take a vote
that's normal what do you think about it
right thank you well i'm afraid that's
that's not possible
thank you very much uh mr smith
okay thank you right out of four
declarations of interest um
as you know you should declare it at the
gender item and
as it says there nature of your interest
so i might
solve a few problems in the future
possibly
um five then there's agreement between
part one and two
there are no part two items
six is correspondence and i don't have
any and i don't think that the chief
executive
has either do uh steve uh that's right
no i don't okay so seven is uh
procedural rule a9 and we don't have
anything under that
so now we go to item eight which is the
annual meeting of the council
and as you can see you have a report in
front of you
of options and i would um hand over to
the leader of the council
i think um cancer james would you like
to uh
lead on that or d first one
i'm not sure whether steve was going to
go first but i will i'll pick it up
right um as you know um ladies and
gentlemen
the rules i know that after may the 7th
we cannot at the moment subject to a
court case that we believe will be
the lga are pursuing next week on the
21st
but as things stand at the moment we
when not
expected to use zoom meetings after may
the 7th
that obviously will cause problems if we
remain with the meeting as of the 17th
of may
because at the moment we will have
problems with
an area large enough to cater for all
members to attend and
also that will be complicated because at
the moment we are still
subject to safe distancing and the
maximum number of people that can be
involved in a meeting
so what we've looked at is that we have
concluded that
probably the most sensible thing to do
is to move the
agm back into april to the 26th of april
to a full council meeting where we can
actually
have the agm on zoom
um and that means that everybody and the
public can be involved in that meeting
now obviously we have the different
options and i would suggest at the
moment we go for option c
which is that we go with the 26th of
april
subject to what legislation appears over
the next few days
um and if then um
is possible in so much is that we can
find a large enough area
to cater with self uh self isolating
areas
so safe distancing and also the
government still insists
that we do not carry on with zoom
meetings
um then we will obviously have had the
agm
and we can just carry on as normal so i
would recommend
at the moment that we go for option c so
that we can actually have the agm and we
can move forward
because otherwise we could be waiting
for may or june
and still not sure where we are um
we we're hoping that there will be
something come out in the
legislation because obviously the
complication is between
april the 26th and the 7th of may there
are county council elections
and there will be some um knock-on
effects
but we think but on balance is better to
get on and do the
full council meeting on the trent at the
agm on the 26th
so that's my recommendation chair is
there a second or for that
may happen jay you got two hands
councillor lock and councillor jones
yes i see right cancer we've got a
second although haven't we
cancer hacking i think tell you a second
is that right that's correct yes
thank you councillor hackett right so uh
councillor locke
yeah well i always got a second if um
because i'm a member of the society of
local council clerks
um and i also went to a zoo meeting that
was held by
dolph um and they've recommended as
steve as um
our leader has said that all meetings
will stop on soon
and i think it's the only option open to
us really because they also recommended
that even if you go into a hall
you've got to be socially distant you've
still got to wear masks
you're advised not to take any paperwork
with you you're advised not to pass any
paperwork around
and advise not to share pets and pencils
that just makes
absolute sense to bring the agm forward
to the 26th of april so i'm all in favor
of them
thank you next one is uh cancer wiseman
thank you chair um did councillor james
mean to
me to propose a and c because c don't
make any sense without a
sorry yes yeah i should have done
something uh sorry counselor wiseman
um we should be that we rescheduled the
meeting
to the 26th and then obviously if there
is any changes in that time
we can reassess it then so it'd be anc
thank you you see right cancer you're
happy and i'm happy with that amendment
yes thank you chair thank you
okay thank you council wiseman good job
somebody's reading this stuff
good uh okay so next one is cancer jones
thank you chair no i've i've spoken
often about the
virtues of these online meetings and and
how i believe that we should be carrying
on
with them in some form whether a hybrid
form or or allowing more of the online
meetings for committees
i just wondered whether as it is a
central government decision whether we
have sent
to central government the result of our
internal survey that we did amongst
officers and members to give them some
information on what things are like on
the ground so that they know
how councils are actually feeling about
these meetings
so the decisions they make are actually
informed by us um
rather than just what they think we want
all right
um steve harris i believe we did send
that back didn't we uh thank you
that we didn't send that particular bit
of that particular document back what we
have done
is we're working um across with
other districts and the county council
across devon
and have fed in our responses to the lga
via that route
and also there's a meeting tomorrow i
think with devon mp
so the information in terms of wanting
to continue
with virtual meetings has been fed back
by us via other networks but not in
terms of
sending our particular report right
thank you for that
councillor christie thank you yes i'm
just going to point out that
i think this is a good idea because um
biddeford town council were moving our
annual parish meeting back
in order to hold it on zoom uh one thing
i have found interesting is that mps
aren't abandoning zoom until june the
21st
oh well you must know by now cancer
christie there's a one more rule for
them and one for us
surely that doesn't come as a surprise
never mind so um
okay so no not everybody's spoken uh
council james did you want to come back
in
no all i would add is that i've also
been lobbying with the
lga um as part of the court case
where they are um pushing for it and
then
uh we had a webcam with uh robert
jenwick last week
where he was doing a very good
politicians
act of edging his bets a little bit on
it
he was sort of complying with what the
government dictates about
stopping on the 7th of may but he was
also leaving the door open that should
the court case
or other factors um come into effect
then they would carry on with zoom
but at the moment we are where we are
with the legislation
is that it stopped something so if i
could just reiterate because i did can
cause a bit of confusion that i'm
recommending a
and c right thank you uh now cancer
watson
yes sure yeah there's no no no further
hands raised
oh isn't there okay i just got some
other ones there sorry okay well in that
case i'll go to the vote
it's been proposed the second did that
we go for uh the
recommendation a and c
so sandra we want to start with that
okay thank you chad councillor bowton
for
councillor brenton abstain
cancer bright four
councillor brown or councillor bushby
or penciller christie or
pencil craigie or
penciller dart
for counselor gab
or kenzler hackett
or councillor haims or
pencil harding or councillor hawkins
paul councillor heppel
um abstain and just for clarity the
reason for my abstention is that i will
not be available to attend the zoo
meeting on monday the 26th
thank you councilman harper councillor
hex or
cancer hudson paul pencil halley
or councillor inch or counselor james
or chancellor jones
or councillor langford
for cancellar laws
okay
i think he's left the meeting sandra oh
right okay thank you uh
councillor mckenzie boy
penciller manly or
counselor newton or
councillor pennington against and the
reason is i believe we should be more
supportive of our lga
thank you councillor rossi
for penceler watson
and councillor wiseman oh
thank you
that's 28 for one against
and two abstentions chair
thank you very much sandra thank you
councillors who moved to item nine in
leveling up fund and community renewal
fund
report on page uh starting at page 36 so
who's leading on this
um sure
sean here i'll take this one chair here
sean go ahead so
yeah thank you very much the purpose of
the report in front of you is obviously
to uh
introduce you a couple of new funding
opportunities that were announced by the
government
in the budget and to seek your approval
for how we proceed with applications to
them so first you have the
leveling up fund the leveling up fund is
a fund that's designed
to support local investments in
infrastructure
it's a four million pound pot for sorry
four billion pound pot of money
that we can make application to only one
bid
is allowed per district and each bid
interestingly that bid should be
supported by the local mp
um the deadline for submissions is the
18th of june
and there are three priority areas for
applications so they've they've told us
that
priority projects will be transport
investment regeneration and town center
investment
or cultural investment it's a capital
fund
for application the community renewal
fund
is a different type of fund it's a
revenue fund
it's a smaller pot of money and
it's intended really that innovative
smaller scale trial projects are pulled
together
and they would then produce evidence for
further applications to the later coming
shared prosperity fund skills
local business investment investment in
communities in place
and supporting people into employment
are prioritized
and we've been working with the county
council to pull together a package of
proposals
uh interesting thing with this one is
the county council of the lead authority
and not us and we will supply
the county council with priority project
ideas that they will put into a
submission to the government
um the we've already been given some
money or allocated some money
to work up projects for this um
for these two funds and you'll see in
the financial implications section that
we've been given 125 000 pounds
for the leveling up fund and 140 for the
community
renewal fund torridge is in priority one
of
three for both funds which gives us a
competitive
advantage in our application um but
recognizing the need for levelling up
and extra investment to the area and
that leads me to the
recommendation so in terms of the
recommendation we're seeking your
approval that
the isaac's yard project which was our
future high street project for biddeford
would be our logical submission for that
it's the only project that we have
that is sufficiently worked up to be
ready for the application deadline and
is impactful enough
uh to make a real mark on them
it's also a project of the appropriate
scale so we're asking for your
approval for that to be our submission
there and that we work with the county
council
uh to pull together a package of
proposals for the community renewal fund
and with that chair could i pass to
councillor hicks as the lead member for
economy because i neglected to seek his
comments
in the report thank you uh
sean uh yeah councillor hicks uh thank
you mr chairman
to me it's obvious that we've got to go
forward with the isaac's yard
we're ready uh everything's lined up
um we've got to have a go
we are the only one in this category one
you read the morning news and easter
terribly upset because their category
three north devon then they made it into
category one
so i would be hopeful that we could well
be successful with that one
with regard to the community renewal
fund
we'll have to see how it goes but we're
there
we're tied in with west devon to some
extent because it's the mp
it has to support it you can only
support one
application so it may be that west devon
get ahead of us there
obviously if we failed with the high
street
under the leveling up we could try it
for the community renewal
it's got to be good somewhere but the
recommendation has written is spot on
would you would you propose that
recommendation
oh second now thank you canister bush
pete good do you
uh i've got your hand cancer push me one
well that's it i just wanted a second
though oh thank you
okay anybody uh we should speak
counsellor um
no that's it isn't it um councillor
haims has raised
yeah what is it 160 000 the leveling
fund um to go to the high street that's
not going to make much of a
impact is it on that project i thought
we were talking millions
when we put it in the high street
application so can you clarify that
please
i can answer that one here yeah am i
unmuted no
no yeah i am sorry my tab seems to be
playing up
um so so the money we've been allocated
125 000 pounds
that's for to develop the project
further towards application
uh the previous scale of project was i
think that they would tell me if i'm
wrong was a 4.7 about 5 million pound
ask was it to the
to the fund yeah it was yeah um and
i it would be logical that we'd be
looking for a similar if not slightly
larger amount of money
from the leveling up fund for the uh for
the biddeford project
um this the 20 million pound cap on
applications to this fund so it's it's a
suitable sort of scale
of project for the fund thank you sorry
i misunderstood thank you
right uh thank you chair yeah as a
councillor hicks
uh alluded to there's only one bid per
mp
do we know if west evan has any
particularly you know
threatening bids that they're trying to
push through as well
any ideas coaster hicks
so uh so chair i can i can sort of
answer that and i think i don't know
whether steve wants coming because he's
also been talking to
um to west evan i i'm not i'm not
particularly okay with what
the west devon's approach is but we are
the priority one
area for that particular fund and so we
are
um it would be logical that you would
seek to
prioritize any application from torridge
as opposed to any other devon district
and certainly west evan
being in um uh jeffrey cox's
constituency area
but um i i steve probably knows more
about west evans intentions than i do
right uh thanks thanks cheschley
continue yeah um i i guess it would be
um unfair to kind of stipulate publicly
what
west devon are doing because i don't
know whether they've taken any decision
through their
uh commit formal committee processes yet
um the leader councillor james
and i had a meeting with the leader west
devon councillor jury
and the chief exec andy bates uh that
was a
kind of an initial kind of private
meeting if you like just to
start to develop a discussion so it
would it wouldn't be
uh particularly good for us to publicly
say what west devon may or may not be
doing at this stage chair
right thank you councillor james has
also got his hands upside down if you
want
to comment on that yeah councillor james
yeah
i was just going to say exactly what
steve said we had a very productive
informal discussion with councillor
jewelry and andy bates
and the aim of which is to utilize
to the maximum what we can do working
together
i think that's as safe as i can go at
the moment
but that's where we are so long ongoing
discussions
thank you councillor christie yeah thank
you it's good that
we are getting a second bite of the
cherry as it were for the um
the high streets fund but could i ask um
we did get a report back uh from the
people
organizing it about our bid can i ask
did that go to the land owner
in this case because um i think the land
owner
actually needs to see that if he hadn't
seen it because there is quite a major
issue highlighted in that report
can i ask if he has seen it uh
chair no no the the feedback wasn't
given detailed feedback wasn't given to
the landowner
but obviously if we get your approval to
proceed with this project negotiations
with the landowner will need to
recommence and and obviously that
information will be imparted
thank you i think it does need to be
um councillor hicks did you want to come
back
nope yes please
yeah okay if you read the morning news
and the compton times etcetera
reading between the lines it seems
obvious to me west evan will go for the
railway line between plymouth no campton
right i believe they had a meeting this
morning didn't they
i don't know i haven't seen the paper
tomorrow no no
oh i i'm just i've just got um
information i received put it that way
all right um
okay so there's no more speakers i don't
think um
is that right uh that's correct chef
thank you very much i'll go to the vote
now
the recommendation is or the
recommendations are on page 40
and it's quite simple so um we'll we'll
go for that then
it's been proposed a second so chandra
thank you chair councillor bounton four
councillor brenton four pencil bright
four penciller brown four
chancellor or
councillor christie or cancer craigie
or penceladops
yup four
councillor dub or councillor hackett
for councillor haynes
for councillor harding
most definite for pencil hawkins
paul councillor heppo
four chancellor hicks
four hudson
council hudson
sandra her screen's gone black and she's
not responding so i'd move on
okay thank you councillor harley or
cancer wrench
cancel wrench
no we've now lost cancer inch okay thank
you tom
councillor james or councillor jones
councillor langford four
penciller laws four hence the leather
or pencil mark
pencil lock or
counselor mackenzie four
pencil manly paul
henson newton paul councillor pennington
councillor rossi
for councillor watson
what councillor wiseman oh
tom have either of the other councillors
councillor hodgson or councillor inch
join the meeting no they haven't sandra
okay thank you that's unanimous sencha
thank you very much sandra
so now to item 10 which is a covenant
for the hotel site westwood ho
we've got a report on pages 41 to 44
with uh recommendations either roar
on page 43. chair councillor laws has
raised his hand
laws uh yeah i wish to declare an
interest
and uh i will blank my screen and turn
off my mic
what sort of interest uh i've previously
voted i'm pre-determined against
oh okay thank you uh
chair councillor hicks says as well
raised his hand
for hicks i have to declare a peculiar
interest the bidder for the land is a
client of mine on
other matters right thank you
right um speakers councillor bushby
oh i've got my hand up yeah we haven't
got any more speakers
no more speakers so somebody needs to
move something then on these
recommendations
um either a or b right i'm sorry i
thought there was going to be a report
there is a report well there is a report
yes i thought an officer was going to
update us but from my point of view um
if you want to move to the
recommendations i was
that the item has been to cnr cnr
decided not to remove the covenant it
went to
ons who come back with um
a slightly um more complicated one
where we could end up discussing what
exactly is meant by
commercial use that went back to cnr
seeing our stood by
that they do not want to remove the
restriction
therefore i will move the recommendation
a
to accept the decision of cnr not to
remove the restriction
restrictive covenant from the land
right thank you for that there's no
second of that please a second that
counts a lot
thank you councillor lock so let's
propose a second in for
uh option a on the recommendation
so we've got a speaker now um tom yeah
councillor brown and councillor hurley
chair elsa brown
thanks chair i was just going to second
it too
all right thank you for that um so
cancer hurley
thank you chair uh councillor james had
just summed up my feelings exactly
uh cnr decided uh against removing the
covenant who went up as
uh went to um internal
and it came back to cnr and they still
decided not to remove the covenant so
what ken james said council james said i
fully endorse so
i would go for a as well thank you thank
you right so thomas no more speakers is
there
no that's correct chair right thank you
your coaches vote now then sandra
thank you chair councillor bounton uh
for
councillor brenton or councillor bright
or councillor brown or
pencil bushby again
it's little christy oh
uh cancer craigie or
panther dart
sorry cancel a dart for
counselor gab or boyfriend
counselor kit for
chancellor haynes for
councillor harding
that's the harding against
cancer hawkins four
councillor apple against
councillor hicks
no he's at the meeting he's declaring an
interest he's loving
thank you councillor hodgson for
councillor harley or
councillor inch abstain
counselor james ball
cancer jones against
counselor or
cancer leather or
canceller lock or
canson mcgough didn't rejoin the meeting
tom that's correct sandra
thank you council mackenzie
for councillor manly
abstain councillor
chin
canceling newton
no he's not responding sandra okay thank
you tom cancer pennington
or councillor rossi
for ansler watson oh
and two abstentions chair
thank you very much sandra so move to
item
11 reopening of torah's leisure
facilities
i think steve is your leading on this uh
that's right chair thank you um
obviously this we've had a quite a few
meetings on this subject over the the
course of the the last couple of months
and
and this was really about updating you
uh where we are we pick ups on some of
those council decisions uh on the way
through so
obviously we're aware of the
government's roadmap what's allowed to
open and when
um i'll update you what we've provided
in terms of financial assistance during
the year
um then we'll touch on the a couple of
uh council decisions that
the framework within which we are
working to
then look at the the proposals that 1610
put forward to what services they could
open and update you as to what's open
currently
and then looking at future uh support
from
torridge as well as external funding and
then
some conclusions and recommendations
on the next slide please
this just outlines what the government
roadmap
indicates and that indicates what uh
facilities are able to
open and from what date so we've got
step one which has
already passed on the 29th of march is
very little in terms of
leisure that could open at that stage
for us
just really that the skate park and our
external or outside
uh uh paddling pools in victoria park
then obviously the second stage of that
uh took place today
and this is the key bit where um
gyms um other
shops businesses are able to to open
in terms of the the leisure contract
that was around
gyms and swimming but obviously
in terms of being covered compliant so
things like
gym classes aren't able to open as as
yet
uh step three which is uh step three and
four
in the future seventeenth of may
the earliest date for step three and
that's when things like corners will be
able to operate and
fitness classes and so forth sitting
alongside
the roadmap is some task force reviews
around travel and that's mainly around
international travel and holidays
and obviously we'll have seen a lot of
information that the government has
produced
around that over the last couple of
weeks or so
and then there's a review around social
distancing
and we're in a face mask and that's due
to report
at some time shortly and obviously
that'll have an impact on
the way our leisure centers and our
leisure facilities
uh will be able to operate
um so obviously it's been over a year
now since we've had
and been dealing with coronavirus so
we've had
kind of three main periods of lockdown
and only torridge pool has been able to
open during that period and that was
open for a short
period just december obviously it's been
largely recognized and reported that
leisure along with retail hospitality
etc have been particularly badly hit
by the pandemic and obviously we'll face
continuing challenges going forward
clearly it'll be difficult to ascertain
how
much impact that will have on
customers and the use of the centers
and that's something we'll have to
monitor over the course of the coming
months
tom next slide please
um as i said at the outset you've had
quite a few
meetings on this subject area
and i guess the the substantive
decisions we have
currently in place fall from the full
council meeting the 30th of november
then the 22nd of february and then just
a couple of weeks ago on the 29th of
march
so at the end of november that's when we
thought we were coming out of lockdown
facilities was starting to open
so at that time you determined that
we would continue to work with 1610
until the end of the contract and that
at that point looking at reopening
torridge pool
and deferring the other facilities
torrent and pool
and holdsworthy at that point until it
was possible to do so and you'll recall
torrent and pool
at that time was having work uh
undertaken to deal with asbestos
and the final part of that decision
was for myself the chief executive stacy
dorey the monitoring officer
david hayes section one five one officer
to allowed to negotiate further with
1610
costs enabling the opening of torrington
and holdsworthy centers
then on the the 22nd of december fall
council
set aside a budget for this financial
year
of 150 000 to support
our leisure services uh throughout this
current year 2021-22
and i'm sure more recently on the 29th
of march
um you made a resolution that
we work with 1610 to reopen
the three sites in line with the
government road
roadmap that road map which i just
alluded to
and that the 110 000 which we'd bid for
from the national leisure recovery fund
be used and utilized at the discretion
of officers to support the reopening
of those three sites
the support we've provided to date and
this is
during the the last financial year which
is now closed
um was around 184 000
up until the end of december and that
was forecast to be
217 000 by the end
of march 2021 and obviously we'd still
deal
with invoices and final payments for
that that period year and that's why it
says forecast to the end
of march 21. tom can you move on to the
next slide please
um so what exactly is happened to date
uh today being the day
uh things can reopen well torridge pool
opens this morning at 6 15
the pool was open and there were people
swimming
and also the gym facilities opened
obviously
both in line with uh covered
restrictions
in terms of numbers occupying those
facilities
we had and 1610 had been well advanced
in the preparation
of opening torrington pool today
and i know there was um classes or a
club
booking for this evening which had to be
moved to
torridge pool so what happened last week
uh was when everything was being
recommissioned
um it had been noticed that the the pool
water
temperature had slightly fallen and when
the engineers
arrived for the recommissioning works
last week
it was found that the boiler had broken
down so that
that's prevented uh torrington pool
reopening
we had discussions with 1610
and the parts to
repair the boiler have now been ordered
unfortunately those parts come from
france and it's a four to six weeks
delay or time period for those parts
to arrive as soon as they arrive
the work will be done to recommission
the boiler
and the pool facilities obviously
during your last meeting you instructed
us to make sure
that through discussion and
the provision of certification
from 1610 that everything was in place
and safe to operate and obviously for
torridge pool
we received all the the appropriate
documentation
from 1610 and obviously we'll do so for
torrent and pool
um at the point that reopens
in terms of holdsworthy because
of the more substantive works required
to open that center and because
the need to recruit stuff across
the district the opening of holesworthy
wasn't expected to take place until
probably towards
the end of may
in our discussions with 1610 they have
uh commissioned some of those works
um some of the works to to the pool
being things around
sorting out the the tired and
dilapidated
tiling within the pool so that works
being commissioned
we did have discussions with them last
week when it became
clear that torrington pool couldn't open
to establish
whether they could reallocate staff to
holdsworthy
to advance the opening of that center
that was toward the end of last week and
the
the management said they would look in
to see what would be
possible in terms of bringing uh
the reopening of that facility forward
trump to move to the next slide please
um so through our discussions with them
obviously
um there's some constraints
um during the the period of uh
closed down obviously the staff had been
furloughed that some of their staff
substantive staff since then staff have
left there were some staff on contracts
and various types of contracts
so their staffing capacity had been
reduced i think by about 12 or 13 so
there's a recruitment
process and a way to facilitate
bringing their staffing capacity
capacity
up to manageable levels so what they've
done
what they've done as i said was relocate
some of their staff resources
from holdsworthy to torrington and
torridge
being those centers more readily
available for use and those that
have a wider customer base there
as i said works required to holdsworthy
and torrington bear in mind they'd both
been closed for the year and hadn't
started
um being operational as had
torridge pool but obviously those works
are now progressing
and adrian and the team are working
closely with 1610 to ensure
those works progress and advance
with earnest so as i said all the
centers
require plant pool and air handling
units servicing and checks
to be carried out prior to commencement
and all a relevant
relevant certificate certification
required to make sure are they safe and
operational
next slide please
um so in terms of looking forward
um april to june obviously seen as
a recommissioning and a start-up period
clearly until the center's open they
don't know what the the footfall
might be obviously lots of
people have turned to other
exercise be it running cycling
during the pandemic so we won't know
until those services are back
up and running what the level of
customer support and customer
footfall might be so we've kind of
estimated
that during that that period to eight
april to june
there would likely be around 81 000
pounds worth of costs obviously that
might
and probably will change now torrington
pool
has to be kind of decommissioned for a
short period of time
however we think um that
1610 will be eligible
for sixty thousand pounds government
uh kickstart uh grant which obviously we
provide
to all sorry not all to all eligible
businesses across torridge where where
whereby their hot weather their
hospitality
leisure and so forth
post june uh 1610 has
deemed what they call a rebuild phase
and that's trying to rebuild
their customer base back to hopefully
uh what it was uh pre-pandemic
but obviously time will tell and see
they'll be doing
marketing campaigns and exercises to try
and build that back and obviously
uh we would work with them in terms of
communications
so i indicated we'd uh submitted a bill
to the national leisure recovery fund
we had initially been allocated 110
000 and that's specifically to help
uh get leisure back on its feet
and more specifically leisure contracts
such as the arrangements storage has
with our provider
unlike those authorities that
might have in-house services whereby
they were eligible to claim lost income
through the
different government scheme we had to
submit a bid
for national funding our allocation has
since
increased to 117 000
and as i said earlier you'd allocated an
additional
hundred and fifty thousand sales period
numbers for
this just this financial year uh within
the the 21 22
uh budget to assist uh financially
our leisure services back on feet on
under its feet
uh so what we do on a month-to-month
basis is
work with 16 10 on an open book basis
and retrospectively analyze their
income and expenditure statements
uh to ensure from a financial financial
perspective we're happy with the
information we are being provided with
uh before making any supportive
payments to them and obviously we've
been updating you
um as and when completing the next slide
is
um i think that's actually it sorry
chair
uh so that's that's where we currently
are and
that's what's up open and i think i was
gonna hand over to the
the leader to make any final remarks
all right uh councillor james all right
thank you chair thank you steve
well is it i know it's frustrating
um we've been through this time and time
again um
and we've we've had a full set up there
i'd like to simplify it a little bit by
saying that you know we we have got 117
000 um from the leisure fund which we
can only use for that
which is to start up and we've backed it
up with 150 000 in the budget
we've got the figures roughly that this
cost us for 18 grand in january
roughly the same in february possibly a
little bit more in march
and going forward it might be as much it
might be dependent on the usage
of around 30 000. i think
that what we have to look at is what are
we trying to do
and to my mind we are trying to do a
couple of things
one is to get to the end of the contract
with 20 uh 16 10
which will be the start of next year
2022.
and the reason we need to look at
getting to that is simply that we need
to be
providing the service that we are
obliged to serve
to supply which is the um
that we will be providing the leisure
services to the best of our ability
obviously no with the government opening
things up
it's looking slightly better obviously
the torrent and pool we could have done
without at the moment
so we are moving forward so i think
in summary rising what i would like to
propose is
that we do stick with the decision to
work with 1610
to the end of the contract um i think we
can say that we will be having
uh discussions about what happened in
2020
um beginning of 2020 but at the moment
our concentration has to be to stick
with
1610 to get to through this year
we need to provide the services people
expect which is
depending on the weather um if we get
holiday makers they may be looking for
indoor
leisure pursuit and our own local people
will
probably drift back towards using that
in order to keep fit
and get more socially active and so we
need really to
expect officers so to work with 1610 to
get them all open
i would hope with this situation with
tower which we might be able to get
holes with the open a bit sooner
but obviously it it's a matter of which
staff you use rather than just
moving um any old staff so
we will progress with opening up and the
cost of support
and we will progress with the
discussions to for the completion of the
work
so it doesn't my proposals don't quite
fit
with what's on the paperwork but i'll
apply it and just ask for members to
support
that we work with 1610 to the end of the
contract
we continue to push to get all three
centres open as soon as possible
so that we can provide those facilities
both for our local communities
and for any influx of holiday um traffic
we get during this summer
the the our officers ensure that we do
so
keeping the costs under control and that
we use the
117th house initially which
um we've been given to do and that when
you can use the
150 backup from our budget
and so i'd ask for somebody to recommend
that and for us
obviously we'll probably need to reword
that for sandra
um to make sense of it i'll second that
yeah
thank you chad i'm so is that councillor
watson
yeah thank you uh right so uh
sandra has written that down i presume
yes he or somebody has
because that's what we'll be going to
vote on if you're proposing that
councillor james
and it's been seconded so that's what
that's what the vote will take place on
all right do you want me to appease it
well i i think it it yes it does need
repeating really because
because it is slight variance to what is
the recommendation on page 52 isn't it
yes it is yeah so simply very simply put
chair
is that we keep on talking about it we
need to get on we're we're making
progress
um not as fast as i would like to be
absolutely honest
um but our option other than working
with 1610
in the short term is negative we would
end up closing all those facilities
and that's not an option
okay yeah right okay
so that's the resolution in front has
been posed a second
now we had a huge debate about this last
meeting
and uh i think we teased out the salient
points which are basically that we do
want obviously our election facilities
open as soon as possible
at the same time we have a little choice
but to work with 1610
but they will be monitored financially
very tightly so we're not giving
anything away
and as soon as we get every facility
open subject to government
restraints then we should do that so
we've got
tom have you got any um speakers at all
or um any house
of course quite a few chairs awesome
okay
first i'd have to tell you councillors i
don't wish to re-run
what we had at the last meeting
everybody virtually spoken at the last
meeting and all points are raised
we're not redoing that again i should
just move to the vote if we start
entering that uh avenue okay so um
councillor bushby's first councilor push
me thank you chair
so i'm not going to prolong that very
much and i'm quite supportive of the
document but i've got um
the proposal rather and i've got a
question for the officers
regarding torrent and pool um of the
hundred and seventeen thousand pounds
that we've got from
you know government funding is there any
way that that money can be used to
replace the boiler
at time rather than spending um a lesser
amount on a repair
uh because clearly the expectation is
that moving
towards the future um if we take this
back in-house or whoever we
uh operate it that boiler is probably
coming to the end of each day
it's clearly you know it's uh this part
is expensive
so it may be make better financial sense
if we replace the boiler
may even be quicker so we can get the
gold open a bit quicker rather than
um you know spending our own money a
little bit later on
replacing an expensive boiler so can we
use any of this money to replace the
ball right
i think saying last time wasn't it why
that that wasn't an option but nevermind
an officer would explain that
chair shall respond if you like so that
that option was
um investigated in terms of replacement
of boiler
the the part replacement is the
responsibility of 1610
but the replacement of the boiler would
be torridge's
uh cost the replacement of the boiler
would be a longer shutdown
than the part um in terms of
thank you for working okay council of
leather i think is next
thank you chair yeah um
i'd like to just ask on the restricted
report that we had last month
there was quite a lot of cost involved
in the first three months urgent urgent
repair work
that the the um contractor we're
responsible for
and i'd just like to ask have they
accepted that and are they going through
those
urgent repair works answer
i'm sure they are going through the
urgent repair works that's one of the
points i made in terms of the works
they're doing at
holesworthy uh pool um
whether they've they haven't accepted
the full list yet we've got a meeting
scheduled for that starts this week
where those discussions will start but
they have started doing some of those
repair works
in terms of the line by line detail um
adrian will be having
discus adria and the team will be having
discussions with 1610 on those matters
this week
to make an amendment to the proposal
i'd like to make an amendment to the
proposal yeah which is
which is that lead lead member
and deputy leader are involved in any
future negotiations
with 1610 there's been no member input
it's just been officers doing
this negotiation and discussions and i
really feel that
it's such an important and turning act
to be such an expensive
issue for torridge that members need to
be involved
in any future discussions with 1610.
if somebody will second it or perhaps
it could be put down as an addendum to
councillor
uh james's proposal well
fine chair thank you for if well i'll
have to ask him
because if council james will accept it
yeah
uh could i i'll just come in there chair
and uh
leather and say that i have asked for
much
better much more regular updates about
where we are
um we can all remember a famous
case um and i'm simply not going to be
in a position of leader of this council
where
at the end of a week or end of a
fortnight or end of a month
i'm told well this has happened i we
need it to do
much more so in terms of that council
leather i have been involved in
some of them but not very many
discussions and i think
um it would be a positive move um that
we were more involved as
members
i'm quite happy with that right you
accept council and others addendums
to your proposal then yeah
right good are you happy with that
council nether
yes thank you chair all right good okay
next one councillor lankford
thank you very much chair uh just to say
um
i'm fully supportive of councillor james
recommendation
um our communities desperately need
these facilities open
our young people our children they we
need to all we can
um to get them out and keep them open
until we can get to the end of contract
and um councillor cottle honking asked
me to
um say that on her behalf as well thank
you very much
thank you very much councillor rich
you have a hand raised yeah thank you
chair
um yeah i i i am fully
supportive of all this uh this uh this
uh proposal
but um just be aware um
cancer uh james that uh we need to
take into account the customers here who
are
they're using our facilities some of
them
i've been they've been in contact with
me they've had direct debits
and they've had these uh cards that
they've put
money on their cards and they are really
worried about
where that finance where their finances
are going to go i just i just wonder if
you can
um sort of flag this up to
1610 and make sure that we are
um you know representing our customers
here
because they're the ones that are paying
for all this you know
and and i think we need we need to
protect them
more than we are at the moment i don't
think we are
because uh you know they're still
playing direct debits and
they've still got 20 30 pounds on their
cards and
they want to know if their money is safe
and
that's that's where i'll put that from
well i'm sure the council underwrites
that
or it should do however okay thank you
for that
i'm sure that'll be taken on board by
the officers yeah
jones is the next one
thank you chair i know it's good to hear
that things um at least seem to be
moving in the right direction
but i say i will reserve judgment until
i see holes of the back open again
i just had a couple of points i wanted
to race um
although i agree with councillor james's
um
slim down proposal which is put forward
do we not want to include the third
recommendation which related to
making it clear that as a council we are
making any grants based on a
discretionary basis and not on a
contractual basis
and to make that a very clear and firm
stance
from us so they know exactly what our
view on that
is i i think that should still be
included and just just for clarity
councillor leather said um with member
involvement he said
the lead member and debt leader did he
mean by that
the leader and deputy leader sorry to be
fussy but
just just a bit of clarification please
thank you
yeah that's what i mentioned you did
okay thank you leader and deputy leader
chair
deputy leader yeah that's right fair
enough okay
and just say i've had a discussion with
our uh solicitor today
and she is still making it very very
clear
to 1610 that the change of law
does not affect the discretionary
um approach that we we apply
um so um that has been made very clear
but i'm i'm happy if we accept my rest
of uh my
resolutions together with coastler
leathers i i will make sure that's
made crystal clear to our officers but
as i say
in my discussions with stacy today she
is still standing on her ground on that
and i will
um commend her on that she's been very
firm with them about
what we do is discretionary thank you
jeffrey
let me interrupt thank you thank you
councillor pennington very brief the
support councilor leather's very
clear uh addendum then to the the motion
it needs member involvement absolutely
from that point of view
my question also relates to the part two
that we had on march 29th
is appendix 2 still relevant or has that
all been superseded now
chase lay respond yes please obviously
that was a part two meeting i'm assuming
uh councillor pennington is con uh
concerned about the receipt of
certification in terms of
um the facilities opening and i did uh
say at the start we've had
all this necessary certification for
torridge pool and we will seek the same
levels of assurance and certification
for the other facilities
as and when they're open thank you my
question really
related to the amounts of money that was
the responsibility the contractor within
north to three months
um bear in mind that uh uh report was
written on the 25th of january
um uh so obviously i i don't think the
the contractors saw the report has there
is
contractor senior report now and what
was your view of it
shall i respond again um i did indicate
earlier council pennington that adrian
and the team have a meet have me
meetings scheduled with 1610 to start
this week
okay let's answer the question chair
thank you thank you
uh councillor lock yeah i'm just going
to say i was
bringing the same point as captain jones
mentioned about
bullet point three should definitely be
included in
in its entirety but it particularly says
1610 may not
claim for any losses so i think the
whole of bullet.3 should be put into the
recommendation
is that not covered with yours to cancer
james well
uh to be absolutely honest chair i sat
here reading that
and thinking should we include it um
what i don't want to do is get
overburdened because obviously
the change of law stops taking effect
today as i understand it
but if members want us to reach
reiterate it
and to add it in i'm quite happy to go
with that i just want things simple
so we know where we're going and what
we're doing and then our officers have a
clear steer
to get on with it so if rose want the
solar coaster lock wants to include that
and obviously coaster jones hasn't
alluded to it i'm quite happy to have
that on
but i as i said i know our solicitor is
dealing very firmly with that situation
and obviously the change of law will
drop out anyway so it will become
discretionary
well i think it's important that that is
in black and white for
1610 to see well if
you prepare to come to propose sorry
chair
through the chair currency lock if
you're happy to propose that our second
it and we'll add that on
yes i'll make a proposal that
recommended 1.3 is included
right so that that's a further addendum
then yeah
it may it's not an it's not an amendment
there's an addition isn't it so it's an
attendant so
that makes it easier doesn't it for when
we come to voting
right apologies for interrupting
could stacy make a comment on that
uh particular item in terms of the that
lore bit please yeah by always
thank you chair um i i was um just going
to say i think it would be quite
adversarial to put that in
um so members are assured i have set out
our legal position
um in writing it's um to 1610 quite
clearly
um it's hard for me to discuss the full
details we're obviously in a part one
meeting and members are entitled to that
legal advice
um in private um but suffice to say they
do know that they are aware
and the difficulty is it it has been
very difficult at times as members are
aware
um i largely have um stayed out of the
discussions of 1610 because they
automatically and i'm
speaking to the leader about this see me
as quite adversarial as soon as i'm in
that meeting um
whether i am or not just by the very
nature um so i think actually setting
that out to them probably won't help
with the discussions
to try and get the centers open and my
understanding is members
are clear that they want the centers
open and i think if that's put in there
um with this proposal and that they're
gonna see that's quite a contentious act
but if i i can assure members i have set
out inviting quite clearly to 1610
separately
and we'll we'll monitor that um as they
submit the invoices to us going forward
right council heard the solicitor's uh
comments about that uh you who wish to
withdraw that
addendum that you've proposed well not
really because we know what driver we've
had with 16 and 10 we've given them
enough rope to hang themselves
um and i still think it's important that
that's in there for all to see
i respect what stacy is saying to us
right okay well it's um uh the leader
said he'd put it on the end as a further
addendum so um
it's there at the moment sitting there
and at the end of the day it's a
question of the council is voting on on
what's proposed
i'm going to take two more two more
councillors and then we must move to the
vote or we're gonna have a re-run of
what we
had before and i don't turn that down
councillor bright
then thank you very much chair uh i'm
sure officers involved with this will be
uh very diligent
uh with regards to this issue but i do
think i should
and the concerns uh that we should be
reluctant to offer the budgeted 150 000
pounds
where possible you know if it's
something we have to fork out for them
we must but i just think we should
really hold back on that because we know
at the end of the contract it's likely
we're going to end up picking up a very
big bill to do the repair works
so i don't you know i don't want to
spend the money now and
we could when we take it in a house you
know make sure we've got better stuff
instead of patching up what we've got
i you know i'm just you know wanted to
air that and make sure
that i think that's a more sensible
position is that we try and save our
money
and then buy the better equipment later
on rather than just patch up what we
have
now thank you chad thank you councillor
james
that's the last one
councillor haynes did you want sorry
yeah just our muting chip
yeah i'm still not clear what the
proposal is really
but i thought we're going to vote on the
recommendations in this report
which includes discretionary payments um
which has just been proposed by council
a lot
um i thought um i'd just quite like you
to make it clear what we're voting on
really
yes well it's uh we read out now because
we're going to go to the vote now and
uh councillor james did a
version of what was in front of you one
two and three
so council james's uh piece will be read
out
and then there's an addendum on that the
lead members and deputy lead member
more closely involved with it and also
the item three on the recommendation is
there
included as well so that's what we'll be
voting on so
sandra if you if you could read through
uh read out what
uh or tomorrow was wrote it down
what councillor james uh said at the
outset of the
this debate
chair i count that assists
um so it's councillor james suppose that
we work with 1610 until the end of the
contract
to provide the services um and that we
work
with 1610 to get all three centers open
um and officers ensure we do so keeping
costs under control
using the 117 000 grant funding
and 150 000 put aside from the council's
budget
um the only other thing i would say that
was seconded
by councillor watson and then we've got
the
um amend addendum put forward by
councillor lever
that um we work with the leader and
deputy leader so that the leader and
deputy leader are involved with the
discussions of 1610
um so we need councillor watson to agree
to that amendment as well because he
proposed the
he seconded the first proposal put
forward by councillor james
right councillor watson you're happy
with that i'm happy with that if
if the leader is happy with it
i'm happy good i'm glad somebody is
um okay so uh i'm just move forward with
it chair because
i've got to go to the vote i think you
rest assured that members
after all the debate we've had i think
the officers got a very
clear idea of where we're coming from we
want the facilities open
and we're certainly not going to be
messed around with so uh
we're going to get you for money that's
what we're going to get and that will
and that's what you're going to vote on
so i'm going to go to the vote now
is this a point of order well well yes
chad i mean i
i believe that um councillor and cancer
james said that they
wanted to add in um as an addendum again
the the third bullet point the third
recommendation yes so are we voting to
include that as well or not that wasn't
mentioned a minute ago and if so would
councillor watson need to approve that
as well
no yes he would storytell that was my
mistake councillor jones is absolutely
correct the third bullet point in the
report
on page 52 was
um put forward by councillor look and
again i need
uh councillor watson to agree that
edition as well
all right i thought i thought that would
have been seconded that one sorry i
thought
i'm i'm sorry but i thought they were
all it was already in yes
so we all got our little ducks in order
now every in terms of voting
and what would be what would be asked to
vote on good okay then sandra let's
let's let's do it then okay thank you
chair
council about him for
councillor brenton
or answer christy
nancy craigie or cancel the dart
or pencil again up for
penciller high kit for
councillor haims or pencil
harding four chancellor hawkins
four councillor hepple
four chancellor hicks four
councillor hudson oh councillor halley
or chancellor wrench poor
chancellor james or cancer jones
or councillor langford
for pencil laws or
counsellor leather or cancer knock
or counselor
sorry cancer mackenzie for
councillor manly or counselling newton
or cancer pennington or
councillor rossi for cancer watson
and councillor wiseman oh that's
unanimous chair
thank you very much thank you
councillors now it's time to uh
shake the close more sanitary australian
trunks and uh get in there and use these
facilities so that
a certain example for the for the public
getting back to use them again
the moment you get the opportunity
anyhow thank you very much for that
and now we come to item 12 petitions we
don't have any
uh 13 notes of motion we don't have any
so
uh that concludes the end of this
evening's meeting
thank you so much for your participation
and um
good night